[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen schön dass ihr wieder
dabei seid bei Tatort Deutschland ich
bin Mirco und ich bin Stefan ich arbeite
hier eigentlich als der Schreiber im
Hintergrund urlaubsbedingt bin ich heute
aber wieder mal zu hören bei Tatort
Deutschland und deshalb dachte ich mir
lass uns heute mal über meine Schule
sprechen äh moment mal Stefan deine
Schule war das eine Problemschule dass
wir jetzt hier im Podcast drüber reden
müssen ich dachte du wolltest uns
Unterlagen zur barschlafphäre
zusammenstellen na ja pass auf Mirko das
eine hat mit dem anderen zu tun darauf
gebe ich dir ein nach hier wie sagt man
noch mein Ehrenwort
ich wiederhole ich gebe Ihnen mein
Ehrenwort also Mirko ich entführe dich
jetzt in die Stadt Geesthacht an der
Elbe in Schleswig-Holstein und zwar in
das Jahr 1963 das Wirtschaftswunder ist
längst Normalität die 68er haben noch
nicht angefangen wir sind mittendrin
also Deutschland Westdeutschland
befindet sich sozusagen ein bisschen in
der Jugend in Geesthacht steht das
Otto-Hahn-Gymnasium übrigens unweit der
früheren Munitionsfabrik von dem Alfred
Nobel nach dem später auch die
gleichnamigen Preise benannt wurden und
im Jahr 63 haben einige Leute eine
ziemlich beschissene Idee na klar tja
sagen wir es wie es ist ein
Geschichtslehrer an der Schule und der
Schülersprecher Laden Großadmiral ade
Karl Dönitz ans Gymnasium 1 das war der
letzte Staatschef der Hitler Diktatur
hitler hatte den am Kriegsende zu seinem
Nachfolger ernannt dieser Dönitz wurde
bei den Nürnberger
Kriegsverbrecherprozess zu einer
Haftstrafe verurteilt kam aber 1956
wieder frei lebte dann eben in diesem
Kreis Herzogtum Lauenburg so und 7 Jahre
später hält er nun ein geschichtsvortrag
am Otto hahn-gymnasium Geesthacht kurz
OHG ja das klingt wirklich nach einer
sehr beschissen
[Musik]
es muss ja ein ordentlichen Aufschlag
gegeben haben oder ganz im Gegenteil
mein lieber Dönitz erzählt den Schülern
wie gut er eigentlich alles gemeint
hatte und dass die Wehrmacht in dieser
finsteren Zeit eine saubere Weste
behalten hatte also im Kern ist das der
gleiche Dreck wie ein afd-typen aller
gauland heute noch verbreiten und die
Schüler damals die sind begeistert auch
die Lokalzeitung applaudierte der
Redakteur vergisst hat Karl Müller hieß
der der Kante Dönitz nämlich selber aus
dem Krieg er war Schreiber in der U-Boot
Flotte und das klingt nach einer
feingesellschaft die Zeitung das müssen
wir hier auch mal aufklären Merkel die
gehörte damals und noch lange danach zum
Axel Springer Verlag nur mal so als
Transparenz sind weiß bei der
Bergedorfer Zeitung so hieß diese
Zeitung zu der die gesagt hatte auch
gehört hatte da kommt jetzt übrigens
noch ein übrigens da hat ein gewisser
Axel Springer auch mal gearbeitet der
machte da ab 1932 seine
redakteursausbildung die wir
Journalisten ja Volontariat nennen
moment mal also du warst an der gleichen
Schule wie Uwe Barschel und bei der
gleichen Zeitung wie Axel Springer yep
also dann wird es hier wirklich sehr
autobiografische Podcast ja irgendwie
schon andererseits ich bin ja damals wie
heute nur ein Erzähler also lieber
zurück zum roten Faden man sieht die
Aufarbeitung der Nazi Diktatur die hat
lange gedauert bis weit in die 60er aber
zum Glück werden 1963 dann eben doch
noch überregionale Medien auf diesen
unzähligen Vortrag aufmerksam die Schule
gerät unter Druck die Lokalzeitung
übrigens auch und auch das
Kultusministerium in Kiel zuständig für
die Schulen und schließlich ist der
damalige Direktor des OHG Georg Rüsen
hieß der so verzweifelt dass er Suizid
begeht man habe ihn wurde bei uns in der
Stadt erzählt im Februar noch in der
Nähe des Hafens gesehen und mehrere
Wochen später wurde dann der toter
Körper entdeckt und soweit diese
tragische Geschichte lieber Mirko und
ich sage dir jetzt wie der
Schülersprecher hieß der Dönitz
eingeladen hatte lass mich raten Uwe
Barsche tja du bist ja kein kleiner
Dummkopf ne aber genau Uwe Barschel war
einer meiner Vorgänger als
Schülersprecher des OHG und er sollte
mich damals wie heute auch dann eben als
Journalist beschäftigen lass uns mal
kurz gucken wie es mit ihm nach der
dönitzaffäre weiterging also quasi bis
eine Affäre nach ihm selbst benannt
wurde und das ist böse aber zutreffen
Mirko ich will aber ruhig einmal eines
sagen zur Zeit in dieser dönitz-affäre
war schon noch keine 20 der ist also in
etwa so alt wie mein Sohn jetzt und er
war natürlich ein Kind seiner Zeit ich
will ihn mit dieser Geschichte jetzt
also nicht frühzeitig schon als
Bösewicht brandmarken also nach dem Abi
studiert Barsche Jura und wird
Rechtsanwalt und Notar und jetzt kommen
wir zu den politischen Akten die du auch
hast Mirko also zur barcial Karriere und
zur Barsche Affäre zu barcels Weg in der
CDU erstmal richtig Uwe Barschel ist
schon seit 1960 Mitglied der Junge Union
also der Jugendorganisation der CDU von
1967 bis 1971 wird er sogar deren
Landesvorsitzender in Schleswig-Holstein
er steigt kontinuierlich auf von 1973
bis 1981 Chef des Kreisverbandes der CDU
Mitglied des Kreistages ab 1971
Landtagsabgeordneter 1973 Vorsitzender
der CDU Landtagsfraktion
1979 Finanzminister in
Schleswig-Holstein und schließlich ab
dem 4 oktober 1982
Ministerpräsident von Schleswig-Holstein
das wird dann nicht nach einer Wahl
sondern nachdem sein Vorgänger Gerhard
Stoltenberg Finanzminister unter Helmut
Kohl geworden war ein Jahr später
verteidigt Barschel aber die absolute
Mehrheit der CDU im Norden und wird als
bundesregierungschef bestätigt also
bitte hier ist Uwe Barschel auf dem
bisherigen Höhepunkt seiner Laufbahn
eine Lichtgestalt mit 34 war ein
Minister mit 38 Ministerpräsident auch
privat gibt an diesen Jahren eine gute
Figur ab Barsche heiratet die
Aristokratin freier von Bismarck die
beiden bekommen vier Kinder mein Hobby
ist meine Familie sagte mal im Wahlkampf
tja in den 80ern wurde man für so einen
beknackten Spruch noch nicht aufs
gelacht die Glückssträhne hält aber
nicht an den Barschels stehen
dramatische Monate bevor bei den
Kommunalwahlen 1986 holt die SPD im
Norden auf Barsche CDU muss empfindliche
Verluste hinnehmen der Junge
Regierungschef wird nervös denn schon im
Jahr 87 stehen wieder Landtagswahlen an
und dann passiert auch noch ein bisschen
seriöser Unfall Barsche stürzt am 31 Mai
1987 mit einem Privatflugzeug ab und
überlebt als einziger
er hat sich an dem Tag in Bonn mit
Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl getroffen auf
dem Rückweg fliegt die kleine Cessna
kurz vor der Landung in Lübeck zu tief
streift einen Funkmast und geht in
Flammen auf im Feuer kommen sein
Bodyguard Bernd Hansen der Pilot Michael
Heise und die Copilotin Elisabeth Friske
ums Leben
Barschel kann sich aus den Trümmern
retten und überlebt wenn das hier ein
Drehbuch für ein Spielfilm wäre dann
würde ich sagen dass es völlig über galt
liebe Kollegen ihr lasst den Antihelden
kurz vor der großen Krise seines Lebens
noch abstürzen und knapp überleben wie
unwahrscheinlich ist denn dieser Quatsch
bitte aber hier ist alles echt Barsche
er leidet zwar mehrere Rippen und
Wirbelbrüche aber er kann ab dem Sommer
87 wieder Wahlkampf machen und das ist
doch bitte nötig denn sein Gegner björn
Engholm von der SPD gilt nicht nur in
Schleswig-Holstein als aufsteigender
Stern auch deutschlandweit ist der mit
40er bekannt schließlich war enghold von
1981 bis 82
Bundesbildungsminister und danach
Landwirtschaftsminister
1983 war im Norden zum ersten Mal gegen
den recht frisch gekürten Barschel
angetreten und verlor aber Umfragen
lassen daran dass die CDU bei der
nächsten Wahl Verluste anfangen könnte
Engholm holt auf Barschel wird nervös
der CDU-Mann will im kommenden Wahlkampf
alles herausholen noch im Dezember 86
hatte er deshalb einen gewissen reiner
Pfeifer als Pressereferenten eingestellt
heute würde man wohl eher PR manager
sagen Mirko aus welchem Verlag kam
Pfeiffer wohl mehr Stefan ich meine ich
habe es ja hier stehen Axel Springer so
richtig allerdings war er dort nur ein
paar Monate für ein Projekt das nie
umgesetzt wurde nämlich eine neue
Zeitung namens der Tag vorher war dieser
Pfeifer bei einer cdu-zeitung dem
weserreport gewesen und anschließend
freier Redakteur was ich dazu gelernt
habe bei der Recherche für diesen
Podcast er hat zwischen hatte ich wohl
auch in der Eisdiele seiner Frau gejobbt
und als grabredner einen einen
Multitalent sozusagen aber jetzt im
cdu-wahlkampf 1987 spielt er die größte
Rolle seines Lebens als wie wollen wir
es nennen Mirko Tim Bösewicht oder Mann
fürs Grobe vielleicht ja fällt her einer
Schlammschlacht auch
Pfeiffer soll offenbar nicht dafür
sorgen dass Barsche gut da steht oder
nicht nur sondern vor allem dafür dass
Engholm schlecht da steht aber
vorsichtig man kann es in diesem Fall
gar nicht früh genug sagen ob Pfeiffer
stets in direkten Auftrag handelte in
wessen Auftrag erhandelte und was er
dafür bekam das blieb später strittig
unbestritten ist aber dass der
Landtagswahlkampf 1987 außergewöhnlich
schmutzig wird Pfeiffer erstatte gegen
Engholm eine anonyme Anzeige wegen
Steuerhinterziehung er lässt engenholm
durch private Detektive beschaffen weil
er hofft irgendeinen Schmutz zu finden
am besten Liebesaffären er versucht
engholms Familie mit Gerüchten zu
verunsichern
Engholm habe Kontakt zu einer
AIDS-Kranken Frau gehabt von dieser
Ekelhaftigkeit könnte Donald Trump noch
lernen eine CDU wahlkampfzeitung enthält
sogar die Behauptung SPD und Grüne
Wolken straffreien Sex mit Kindern die
Liste ist sogar noch länger Pfeifer
hetzt auch die Mitglieder einer
unabhängigen Wählergemeinschaft
gegeneinander auf erfolgreich übrigens
diese Gemeinschaft hat sich gespalten
aber kurz vor dem Finale wendet sich das
Blatt hier sind die ZDF Nachrichten vom
12 September 1987 einen Tag vor der Wahl
entschließt sich Holstein
[Musik]
guten Abend werde Zuschauer am Vorabend
der Landtagswahl in Schleswig-Holstein
sind gegen Ministerpräsident bachel CDU
schwere Vorwürfe erhoben warten das
Nachrichtenmagazin der spiegelberichte
Barsche selbst habe die Anweisung
gegeben den SPD-Spitzenkandidaten
Engholm bespitzern zu lassen dazu
erklärt der Barsche alle Vorwürfe sein
erstunken und erlogen der spiegelberuf
sich auf eine lange altersstattliche
Erklärung des Mitarbeiters in der
Pressestelle der Landesregierung Rainer
Pfeiffer dieser gibt an er sei im Januar
von Barsche beauftragt worden enghorn
Steuererklärung überprüfen zu lassen
später habe der Ministerpräsident eben
Pfeifer den Text Entwurf für eine
anonyme Anzeige gegen Engholm gegen
Steuerhinterziehung diktiert
außerdem behauptet Pfeiffer barcel habe
eine Überwachung engholms angeordnet um
dessen Sexualleben auszukundschaften
Ministerpräsident bastel sprach von
einer beispiellosen Kampagne er äußerte
sich am Abend zu den Vorwürfen in der
spiegelgeschichte und vielen vielen
weiteren wird beschrieben wie die CDU
den SPD-Spitzenkandidaten diffamieren
wollte die Steuer Anzeige der Detektiv
die aidsgeschichte in dem Spiegelartikel
wird angedeutet dass die Bespitzelung
enghorns vom Barsche vertrauten Karl
Joseph Ballhaus ausging der war Manager
beim Kosmetikkonzern Schwarzkopf und
soll den Detektiv bezahlt haben die
Beziehung von Ballhaus zu Barsche gab es
beide hatten unter anderem 1977 eine
Kulturstiftung im Kreis Herzogtum
Lauenburg ins Leben gerufen auch für die
steueranzeige gegen Engholm bietet sich
eine Spur an schließlich sei Barsches
Vorgänger Stoltenberg
Bundesfinanzminister und sein Haus seit
deshalb vielleicht Absender der falschen
Verdächtigungen gewesen
Barsche wehrt sich noch einen Tag vor
der Wahl ganz entschieden am Samstag dem
12.09 1987 gibt er eine Pressekonferenz
ob es eine eidesstattliche Erklärung des
Mitarbeiters der Pressestelle der
Landesregierung am Pfeiffer gibt weiß
ich nicht selbst ich nehme das einem
Vorabdruck des Hamburger
Nachrichtenmagazins der Spiegel
sollten darin die im Spiegel
abgedruckten
Vorwürfe gegen mich
stehen so kann ich dazu nur sagen ich
habe zu keinem Zeitpunkt den Herrn
Pfeiffer beauftragt gebeten bedrängt
oder sonst etwas getan mit dem Ziel er
möge in der politischen
Auseinandersetzung
rechtswidrige oder auch moralisch
verwerfliche Handlungen begehen
insbesondere gibt es keinen Auftrag mit
Hilfe einer Auskunft Teil Herrn
wegen angeblicher homosexueller oder
sonst wie ausschweifender
lebenswandlungen auszustehen oder zu
überwachen und es gibt auch genauso
wenig einen Auftrag oder einen eine
Bitte von mir man möge in den
Steuerunterlagen von Herrn nachprüfen ob
er seine Steuern ordnungsgemäß gezahlt
dies sind ungeheuerliche Vorwürfe
die hier oben in Schleswig-Holstein
können dazu wohl nur sagen er Stunden
und erlogen
ich habe nur die Möglichkeit dies in
dieser Form zu dementieren
und
werde allerdings
mit allen mir zu Gebote stehenden
rechtlichen Mitteln dagegen vorgehen
ohne Rücksicht auf die Betroffenen
ohne Rücksicht auf auf Hintermänner die
ich doch wohl vermuten muss denn anders
ist es ja kaum vorstellbar dass man
angeblich lange zurückliegende Tatsachen
ohne mich damit zu konfrontieren wenige
Stunden vor Ende des Wahlkampfes in die
Öffentlichkeit lanciert kommen wir zur
Wahl Barsche hatte ja schon lange
befürchtet dass es knapp werden würde
jetzt standen ganz kurz vor dem
Wahlsonntag diese ungeheuerlichen
Vorwürfe gegen ihn in den Zeitung und
tatsächlich verliert die CDU in Kiel
ihre absolute Mehrheit die SPD wird mit
Engholm erstmals seit 1958 stärkste
Kraft im Landtag die FDP zieht auch in
den Landtag ein die Grünen nicht kurz
gesagt gibt es ein Part CDU und FDP
haben genauso viele Abgeordnete wie die
SPD mit dem schlesischen Wähler Verbund
also der dänischen Minderheit
normalerweise würden jetzt schwierige
koalitionsverhandlung beginnen zum
Beispiel könnte der Däne Otto Meier sich
ja von CDU und FDP zu einer Mitarbeit
überreden lassen aber das Land ist
politisch gelähmt diskutiert wird nicht
wer regieren könnte sondern was dran ist
an den Vorwürfen gegen Barschel Pfeifer
behauptet inzwischen ganz offen das
Barsche selbst ihn mit der
Schmutzkampagne gegen Engholm beauftragt
hat jeden Tag sie kann neue Details
durch auch in CDU und FDP nehmen erste
Leute Abstand einer Alarmsignal
gleichzeitig stellen sich die Frage
welche Spiel eigentlich dieser Rainer
Pfeiffer spielt warum hat der kurz vor
der Wahl die Seiten gewechselt ging es
nur um die Moral floss vielleicht Geld
Freunde ich kann euch versprechen das
wird noch richtig interessant von allen
Seiten bedrängt gibt Barschel am 18
September 1987 eine weitere
Pressekonferenz und die gilt schon wenig
später als historisch über diese Ihnen
gleich vorzulegenden
beide stattlichen Versicherungen hinaus
gebe ich Ihnen
gebe ich den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern des
Landes Schleswig-Holsteins und der
gesamten deutschen Öffentlichkeit mein
Ehrenwort
ich wiederhole ich gebe Ihnen mein
dass die gegen mich erhobenen Vorwürfe
haltlos sind ich danke Ihnen das
melodramatische Ehrenwort verschafft
barcial aber keine Lust an den
eidesstattlichen Versicherungen die er
seine Mitarbeiter hat unterschreiben
lassen gibt es kurze Zeit später schon
wieder Zweifel schon eine Woche nach dem
Ehrenwort kündigt Basel seinen Rücktritt
an für den zweiten oktober 1987
übergangsweise führt nun sein
Stellvertreter Henning schwarz die
Regierungsgeschäfte aber das
interessiert in dieser Zeit
ehrlicherweise niemanden ich musste den
Namen auch googeln obwohl ich damals ja
quasi dabei war tatsächlich deutet sich
schon im Herbst 1987 an das Leute von
der SPD frühzeitig von Pfeiffers
Aktivitäten wussten und sogar im Kontakt
mit ihm standen entsprechende
Erkenntnisse kommen im frisch
gegründeten Untersuchungsausschuss im
Oktober zur Sprache aber die
Schlagzeilen beherrscht in diesen Tagen
bald eine Meldung aus Genf dorthin ist
Uwe Barsche gereist nachdem er seine
politische Laufbahn schlagartig beendet
hat wie ich damals meine erste breaking
news Lage erlebt habe als Redakteur
einer popeligen Schülerzeitung wie
Westdeutschland von einem großen
Todesfall erschüttert wurde und welche
wilden Theorien bald kursierten das
erfahrt ihr in Teil 2 dieser Ausgabe von
Tatort Deutschland wir hören also
voneinander hoffe ich euer Stefan und
euer Merkur